in Spain soccer and politics have always
been intertwined the country is home to
two of the top teams in the world
football club Barcelona or Bursa and
Real Madrid varsa is a premier symbol of
Catalan identity and pride while Real
Madrid is seen to represent the Spanish
crown and Madrid's rule over Catalonia a
symbolic struggle between the region and
state takes place whenever the two teams
faced off in match ups referred to as El
Clasico now as state officials are
cracking down on the fight for Catalan
independence Spanish stadiums are also
in the global spotlight as a
battleground over the future of this
region
this is bartha's home camp no.4 Catalans
the team is the heartbeat of a region
that's been battling over autonomy since
it was defeated in war by what is now
spain back in 1714
in fact at BOTS against Catalan fans
commemorate that date in a ritual chant
for independence at 17 minutes and 14
seconds into the match
on a night when BOTS that was playing an
away game
we hung out with fans in a rural part of
Catalonia that's considered an
independent stronghold
Karla's rd alice is president of an
association of 3,500 barsa owners who
each share a slice of the fan owned Club
and vote for its president in autumn at
Mediterranean but again said and respond
infants are intimidated appropriate
ellonija your watch this impressing
would let me go a former Girl Scout on
instance independentista see money first
Catalonia is a region in Northeast Spain
that's home to seven and a half million
people its capital is Barcelona Catalan
speak their own language and have their
own flag culture and traditions all of
that was actively suppressed by Spanish
dictator Francisco Franco during his
thirty-six year rule but in stadiums
basa fans would defy Franco by chanting
in Catalan and flying their flag
Franco despised balsa as a symbol of his
failure to erase Catalan identity
aligning himself with Real Madrid
Barcelona Club which was put to the test
when Catalans voting in an independence
referendum were met with state
after the referendum arson played in an
empty stadium why did they do that
you are impartial mediator Perdita
don't study Shiva ramp and receiver
because us operate entirely sensible
same prep Astoria call dear girls Koran
started selling beer InTouch Hispaniola
people who are not panel ' just didn't
Democratic leadership asara Catalunya
Russia you won't believe the football
study copyright notices a school group
ocotillo a parameter significant Gerard
piqué plays centre back for Barza and
the Spanish national team he voted in
the referendum and made headlines when
he spoke out about the state's crackdown
no unico narration Antonia venir a
policía Nacional para
perhaps actual mechanical means by
Sirica Sharon mr. oberkugen for
kirito-kun de the Craig show un problema
ok Mali stoning gun problem and
impartial Allah he can tell me the
future Bartha players are central to
Spain soccer success when Spain won the
World Cup for the first time ever in
2010 seven of its eleven players were
from barsa pique was booed at the
Spanish national team's practice for his
but among fans here his words were
welcomed varsa is very much pro Catalan
though it's never taken a public
pro-independence stance vinet kuya's is
president of a bar Sofia do you think
varsa should be more politicized today
and have a clear stance on independence
think Anthony immigrants matter teleport
era una persona Kira Clara me even stop
a Clara militancy together I'm
independent Eastman like Institute the
12 mm II can be worn see no see no
personal me do correct Cassie present in
your personal call must in Sochi dolls
most kayaks have to see personal amento
grekes ecommerce or even to be seen a
group the kikuna sama put all that was
in the key is how opposition to the
stadium
[Music]
the issue of independence is divisive
throughout Catalonia and some soccer
fans think politics should be left out
of stadiums entirely so I'm on my way to
meet Eric who's a young Catalan and
we're gonna take a train to a soccer
match to watch his team ass venule play
they're the second biggest team in
Catalonia and they're part of La Liga
which is the Spanish Premier League hi
how are you nice to meet you I'm Dina
espanol has always been a club for those
in Barcelona who identify with Spain
rather than Catalonia like Eric and his
friend unhealth who didn't vote in the
October 1st referendum because they felt
it was illegitimate how do you describe
the relationship in Spain between
politics and football in Spain we tend
to pologize lots of things and here in
Catalonia also the people tries to play
dice football saying that for example
independent after independence people
and Spaniards court of law if things
have the club's taken a position in
topic that it's not a sport topic it's a
political topic and in my opinion the
football teams and the sports teams
that's not maybe it may not have an
opinion in the inequality in the
bathroom they always sing independence
independence
72 I'll in Spanish Stadium will never
see me that so you don't think you'll
see any of that tonight
no no chance it's very uncommon in the
stadium to see this place
we're sitting in the nosebleed section
but I took it to Molly 25 euros
you've got season ticket but the real
fans are down there unlike the box of
stadium here you don't really see that
many flags you don't hear any
independence chance or anything really
political people here are just trying to
enjoy the game
[Music]
[Applause]
today traditional rivalries and Spanish
stadiums are amplified with the
divisions over Independence Real Madrid
opted to leave its team bus at home for
a recent match in the independent
stronghold of Girona as a security
measure it also does so whenever the
team plays at Camp know the home stadium
of barsoom as the fate of Catalonia
remains uncertain one thing is clear
games here will certainly feel like more
than just a soccer match hi everyone if
you want to see more of my reporting
from around the world check out the
videos in the direct from playlists like
when I recently went to South Korea let
me know where you want to see me report
from next and be sure to subscribe to AJ
Plus